Speaker 1: Herschel Walker continues to
double, triple, quadruple down on this fake
police badge. The next the latest example
of this is that Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker brought a bunch of
sheriffs onto his stage at a campaign event
so that he could again flashes fake police badge.
Now, remember, no matter how many sheriffs and
FBI agents and, you know, Secret Service and U.S.
Marshals, I don't care who you put on that stage,
it doesn't make your stupid badge any more
indicative of you actually being a law enforcement
officer. Look at this latest embarrassment.
Speaker 3: I want you guys to know I'm
going to always support them. Yeah,
I'm going to always support them.
Speaker 1: That's the cue, guys. And what's
happening is Herschel Walker is now turning. He
took out his badge and in unison. I mean, look at
it. Just instantly all these guys behind him going
to take out their badges to prove what? To prove.
Speaker 3: What. I'm going to always support them.
And I want to thank them for all what they
do, because what they're doing is toughest
time in the United States of America.
Speaker 1: Whether what they're doing
is the toughest time in the United States of
America or not. Herschel Walker's badge is
an honorary meaningless badge. He's not a police
officer. Think about how far things have fallen,
where there's a guy running who says,
I'm a police officer and he's not.
And people go there, but every other form. He's
just lying. He's just it's just made up. He's
not a police officer. He pulls out a badge. He's
not a police officer, but he says he is. He says
he's trained with the FBI. He hasn't. Yeah,
but I don't know. But he's against abortion.
But he's not because he paid for a woman to get an
abortion and urged her to have another one. Yeah,
but he'll vote against abortion.
Oh, okay. I understand this is an
embarrassment to the United States. Let me know
your thoughts. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman show is, of course, a viewer
supported program, a listener supported program.
The primary means through which that support takes
place is the membership program. You can sign up
at Join TAC Mint.com. You can use the coupon
code, big voting 22 and there is of course very
limited time left until that big voting day in the
United States. You'll get the daily bonus show,
the commercial free audio and video feeds of the
show, and invitations to the world famous truly
world famous members only town halls which are
a really big deal. Join Pacman dot com is the
place to sign up.